[Music]
you were in Australia recently was that
experience like uh I don't like the
wildlife I don't like I don't want to
sound sound angry about it but I am
angry about the Australian wildlife yes
I am because everything that can kill
you right like we're out and it says
that oh my gosh Emma hard I worked to
zoo right across the street you got to
come we'll take you on a private tour so
my girls that oh we gotta go I was like
well just slow down what is the word of
the private tour we'll take you in the
back so you can meet all the animals I
like I don't wanna meet them I don't I
don't everybody go in the back this
koala bears first of all they're like oh
they're so lethargic they're sleep all
the time we get in there they're all up
and they're just look right instantly go
straight the races of these a racist
koala bear I'm about to take a picture
of her like like standing next to koala
bear here but it's one in the tree I see
the koala bear he's about to swipe down
at her head I was so scared that I
didn't tell her I wonder I wanted to
record it first
koala bear did this she's like oh like
he grabbed her hair and she'd went to
like turn to talk to me I was gone I
left I had what I want it's almost like
every creature in Australia can kill you
everything like their butterflies will
have acid oh it's really pretty but
unlike other butterflies this one shoots
acid in your eyeball every animal we saw
was a violent animal like the kangaroos
like I don't like it when you show me an
animal to tell me what that animal can
do if it gets mad like oh these
kangaroos are so happy but if they get
angry they can kick your chest off why
with
they can kill you all the kick with eggs
yeah your hash trick is to take off your
genitals what that's this is a kangaroo
would try to attack you
well first of all I don't need another
information because I'm not getting that
close to a kangaroo prank second of all
everything is dangerous to spiders
there's not regular spiders oh yeah you
guys gotta watch out for those I think
it's a red back or whatever it is yeah
yeah I say small you don't really know
it's there but if it bites you it's over
wait what why we hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please